Chúng myself!
Anh H immort.
Thế chây.
Chúng committed a brauch.
T BC Morgan, ra vội b two đよし, so well said.
Quad, cũng đến noch.
Thì asta để w lam ngư người rỡ保 và ph整.
Có thể nào cùi lần lên...
εν想 con Like.
Bây giờ Sr.
Chúng ta sim ek nướo?
niew hộ
Cái khỏe
Đi
Mình bắt có
Bây giờ
S punt
Đi
Chứ?
Cái xe không bao giờ tất cả
Có nó a cây?
Không có có lữ
Đi
Tình bất m Singer d波
Rất à
Cái bà
và h beep bụng in the end.
Thôi mấy đợi thích quá.
Hãy bắp bắp lại que bria.
Vậy?
Bặc biệt như nửa.
Nói không phải đợi vọng nhé?
Đừng làm.
Thấy đợi thích như...
Tất là tất cả.
Thấy đợi thích như COVID.
Nói bất đợi thích như COVID.
Nhìn chịu itu báo.
Thôi cả, đứa.
Nói bắt đầu bởi hắn.
Thôi bạn có hiểu rap,